hello everybody what is going on welcome
to another bitcoin trading
ish video i'm making this as a sort of
follow-up to the whole
eight percent profit in 30 minutes
bitcoin trading video i did about a
month ago
uh a lot has changed and a lot's been
learned and i've
i figured i could share at least some of
that with you guys uh
so to start that video at the moment has
like a bit over 700 views so not really
that many but by far has been
like it's been the most uh i don't know
interactive or the most
the most contacts i've ever had from any
single video
i've had about 40 emails uh because of
it so far with people
either asking about strategies uh the
bot
uh and even investing in me so within
actually 24 hours i was contacted by
two different people pretty interested
in investing in automated trading with
me one of whom is actually a large
investor
now some more on that in a bit first i
wanted to hit on some of the things that
i've
learned since then so the whole eight
percent in 30 minutes was was really
meant to just be kind of for fun
same thing with the whole algo trading
of bitcoin uh
i just wanted to kind of play around in
some free time with it
uh but without much attention and that
and the people that were interested
bitcoin algo trading kind of uh became a
huge focus for me for
uh quite a bit and still is uh so the
first thing i did was actually back
test uh the simple moving average
crossovers
and the macd crossovers so at like first
glance on something like bitcoin wisdom
or something
you might think that both of those are
actually pretty decent strategies to
trade with i know i sure did
so i thought what would be kind of neat
is i can at least i did back test them
and they are not good uh long-term
strategies
um so what i thought i could do is
actually show you guys a few
uh back-tested strategies like with the
macd
um since actually that's what i was kind
of i was trading on the macd
and then also simple moving averages for
those first few days and i thought it
was pretty good
uh but no so anyways i just kind of
pre-built a couple of scripts here
um to test it and so the first thing
we'll start with
is a low frequency so very high numbers
on the uh the moving averages so what i
have it doing here is here's the actual
graph that it spits out the macd is down
here at the bottom
uh everything the time stamps here are
unix time stamps
uh so anyway
um and it's actually unix plus
um but anyway don't worry about that uh
what we had here was only 17 total trade
solos again
trading the crossover of the macd so you
had to cross over here
uh another crossover here another one
here so you can see basically every
crossover
something changed right and there is
profit
i mean it clearly did you know make some
decent profit here
and it continued going up and then it
kind of dropped down here obviously in
price and
for a brief time it was actually market
beating
but anyway uh that was the low frequency
and then these were just the results
basically so
the total profit you know if you started
everything was starting with one bitcoin
so
the total profit by the end of all this
and after 17 trades and paying a trade
fee i use btc
e's fees for example so it's point two
percent per
uh trade anyway um
throwing all that in we have a
um basically the the total profit was
265 so you did 265 plus the starting
value
of uh bitcoin was you know right over
here like
it was like 249 and two pennies i think
so oh i've actually
written it out here silly me anyway
starting price 249.02
and then the profit was 265. so those
together equaled for
442. um or the buy and hold profit is
442. the ending price is 691
compared to the macd dollars changed
though
we had we basically saw 442 profit if we
just bought and held
versus trading you made 265 so
significantly
less there so so that's that but then
some people might be like well i was
never trading like those
massive trends so that doesn't really
pertain to me
so then i i've got another one here
that's kind of a medium frequency of
trades and i bring it over
so as you can see it's a little more
wild here it's kind of hard to see even
the crossovers
so let's just zoom into like a specific
spot so it's a little easier to see them
now
um so anyways again you can see where
you know profit went up and down it kind
of
tends to go with the trend but it no
matter what it's pretty much under
performance
all the way through uh even in the last
one we actually had some over
performance or
uh you know better performance right
around here i believe
uh but not in this one so that was kind
of the medium but again i'll show you
guys here
this one actually made less money than
the other one
um but kind of looks a little bit more
reliable to me but anyways
made less money um buy and hold again
you would have made 442
versus this silly strategy here 147.
part of the reason why this probably
made a lot less money is you'll see the
total trades
was over 10 times as many as
the trades from the previous uh back
test
and so trade fees are playing a huge
role here
so let's close this one and let's look
at one last one that's a high frequency
so let me bring it on over
this one really drives the point home i
think
you can already see the the loss there
but the graph is just really uh
saddening so you can see here that if
you're trading real high frequency with
the macd for example
uh you are pretty much certain to lose
a lot of money so so anyways those are
kind of the initial
um things that i tested and i was seeing
this and it just didn't look like the
macd
no matter what parameters you chose uh
was a very good idea at all
so then i started looking at like a
bunch of the other indicators just to
see if there was
something i could start with and then we
can start doing
um things like machine learning and even
genetic programming to really hone in on
on getting the most out of our most bang
for our buck so to speak
so i tried the adx which is the uh
average directional movement system
uh the rune indicator emas smas macd
all that stuff uh i tried and didn't
really get too
too far cracked out machine learning and
pattern recognition just to see
um decent results but still nothing
really worth writing home about
and certainly not enough to justify
going live so then i looked into the
grid strategy which if you don't know
what it is it's a fairly basic strategy
where you're just trading based on
preset margins
usually with no stop loss so it kind of
scares a lot of people away
uh but as long as you're you know
bullish bitcoin let's say long term
then you should have absolutely no
problem with that and all of the
investors
uh their goal everyone that's contacted
me for investing their goal is actually
not to make
us dollars they want to accrue more
bitcoin
um so as long as that's their goal then
it actually does kind of
it makes a lot of sense to not uh use a
typical strategy that you you would find
with something like 4x even though the
grid strategy actually is
most commonly used with 4x but actually
it's almost like the trend is not your
friend with the typical grid strategy
but anyways
uh we looked into that um and
so i got started there was seeing a lot
better results then i
pulled out the machine learning
especially for the grid parameters so
you kind of have to set you know a grid
size
and that's going to be dependent on a
lot of different things that i'm not
really going to get into
but um then finally um
we kind of we went live with the grid uh
immediately but there were still some
some small problems and about a week and
a half ago
pulled out some genetic programming just
just for fun and actually came up with
another great variable
that really hadn't even considered yet
and i don't know how familiar
most of you are with machine learning
and genetic programming but sometimes
you'll be actually returned a variable
that you don't actually know what it
even is there's really no way to figure
out what that variable is you just kind
of have to trust it
which is kind of problematic because
there's no way to find out if it's
actually
truthful like a good variable or if your
program
is glitching or something you know so
it's very disconcerting but at least
this one it was pretty easy to figure
out what it was
so that was neat and actually i have
that here as well so i'm going to close
out of this
and this is the ending strategy here
it's a little bit slower it's using this
higher granularity data so it's going to
take a second to do the full back test
and all that
but
yeah so this one um
is a little bit more in depth as far as
the uh output
uh simply because this is what was given
to the investors but
um basically at the end of it you can
see the various results if you convert
it out like
at the end of it we were left with 2.5
yeah everything starts with one bitcoin
right
at the end of it we had 2.56 bitcoin and
we had 1500
uh almost 1600 uh on balance
and then if you converted it all the
dollars it was 3724
versus um the buy and hold 839
and then if you converted it all to
bitcoin uh 4.4
versus obviously if you just held and
then this is just a little graph for it
again unix time stamps at the bottom
plus you know the 1.384 anyway
we're live with uh counts on both gox
and btce now
five total investors the fund's actually
about 150
000 u.s dollars uh and as of our latest
track records out of beta testing we're
currently
already doubling the market which is
pretty awesome uh it's really neat to
see everything take off so fast
and what's also kind of interesting
about the exchanges is with these apis
that they offer so you can actually
connect and trade with a program
um for someone like me to manage someone
else's funds
i just use the api i don't even know
their login info you don't have to
transfer money out
you can't transfer even if you wanted to
all you can do is trade so
obviously that represents a huge
decrease in risk for
you know people uh they don't even give
me their bitcoin besides the deposit so
it's actually kind of neat for everyone
i don't really
see that kind of stuff happening with
investing and like fund management at
all
and maybe that's for a host of like
legal reasons and stuff but
kind of interesting difference uh there
anyway uh enough on that i really just
wanted to kind of add an update as to
what's been up with me and what i've
been doing i've been getting a ton of
emails from a lot of curious people
and i also just wanted to correct a few
things that i had said since before i
was really trading on
sma and macd and i didn't make a lot of
money
uh or at least i didn't make a lot of
money i would say i made a lot of
percentage gain
uh-huh um but it's definitely a
dangerous endeavor
uh so i would not suggest anybody uh go
down that road
so hopefully you guys enjoyed the update
as always thanks for watching thanks for
all the support of the subscriptions
and until next time